alright i love it when Donald Trump gets
caught lying now i'm not talking about
politician lies like look at what Obama
did to the deficit I'm talking about
flat out lies remember when Donald Trump
made fun of that disabled reporter and
later he tried to defend himself by
saying I had no idea the guy was
disabled because I never met the guy
turns out he had met the guy a dozen or
so times before and it is happening
again one of the women who has accused
Donald Trump of sexual assault Natasha
stone of said uh Donald Trump said oh
she's not really good-looking enough for
me to sexually assault her that's what
he said about Natasha stone off with
temple Taggart McDowell he took a little
bit of a different approach now temple
Taggart McDowell is the former Miss Utah
who claimed that Donald Trump forcibly
kissed her in 1997 get a load of this
Trump initially denied by saying I have
no idea who this person is here is a
quote from Donald Trump this is Donald
Trump saying this to NBC News quote I
don't even know who she is she claims
this took place in a public area I never
kissed her I emphatically deny this
ridiculous claim unfortunately reporters
have started looking into that claim and
it turns out Trump is contradicted
himself it turns out that back in May
right we're talking about five months
ago when temple Taggart McDowell's
allegation first was made public in a
New York Times story took Trump as
reported by The Daily Mail said all know
yet I know the story I remember meeting
her she recanted the story etcetera
let's put up that quote from Donald
Trump this is Donald Trump to the Daily
Mail on May twenty-fourth then there was
that nice girl from Utah the one who
said i gave her a kiss she recanted she
said it never happened you know what she
was a nice kid she was in front of her
parents we had thousands of people there
in the audience she said hi mr. Trump
and she came over and gave me a hug and
I gave her a kiss on the cheek huh how
do you go from such a specific and
detailed recollection to not even
remembering her at all five months later
it's sort of weird isn't it you know
what she was a nice kid kiss hug blah
blah blah blah blah I was expecting when
I read the headline this is going to be
more of a gotcha thing where Trump made
some vague reference
her know he talked about her in specific
detail and now he doesn't remember who
she is Pat unusual isn't it for the guy
who prides himself on remembering
everything yeah I for one am shocked
that Trump would make such a declarative
statement at the amounts back and then
completely contradict himself with a lot
of people you say oh we have to look at
the context right and you look at the
context then you say oh it's not as bad
as the headline made it seem it was
taken out of context no big deal with
Trump you get the context and you come
away thinking wow it's even worse than
the headline made it appear to be